On March 30, 2017,
Kendrick Lamar dropped
his video for "Humble."
It was a visual marvel.
In a sea of one eye-catching
shot after another,
it was this 10-second
stretch from 1:57 to 2:07
that people couldn't stop talking about.
♪ Ay, Obama just paged me, ay ♪
♪ I don't fabricate it, ay ♪
♪ Most of y'all be fakin', ay ♪
Today, you can see these
seemingly sporadic,
but precise movements
in a bunch of projects,
like Doja Cat's video for "Boss B----."
♪ I wear the hat, and I wear the pants ♪
♪ I am advanced so I get advance ♪
Kygo and Miguel's "Remind Me to Forget."
♪ Love, keep reminding me, oh ♪
And Jay Rock and Kendrick
Lamar's "Wow Freestyle."
♪ Lil' man mad, I don't wanna go bad on ♪
♪ Big heat stamp fold
out, when you lack on ♪
It suddenly seems like hip-hop
can't get enough of this type of shot
captured by this robotic camera rig.
Sick. [laughs]
But there was a time when this technology
was mostly used for food commercials.
To understand how the cinebot went
from food-commercial staple
to avant-garde music video tool,
we've gotta rewind a few decades.
Music videos have been
around since the 1950s,
but at the stroke of
midnight on August 1, 1981,
a new era in music began.
MTV, the first-ever 24-hour
music video channel,
aired for the first time.
It played The Buggles'
"Video Killed the Radio Star"
as its first video.
♪ Now I understand the
problems you can see ♪
Labels began throwing money into creating
visual components to
help boost album sales,
and the music channel was
the perfect vessel for that.
And 15 years after MTV's arrival,
there was a new player
in the video-making arena
capitalizing on the music-video boom.
This is Jason Rau, the managing
director of Camera Control,
who's been there since the
company's very beginning.
Jason Rau: Back in the day, all the big,
you know, Britney Spears,
Justin Timberlake,
all those big music videos, we worked on.
Narrator: And they used
motion-controlled rigs,
or cinebots, to make it happen,
though not exactly in the same way.
One of the earliest video projects to use
a motion-controlled camera
system on a big scale
was a long, long time ago.
More specifically, in the
original 1977 "Star Wars" movie.
[pistol fires]
In early sci-fi films,
planet and spaceship models
would move around the camera.
But digital effects pioneer John Dykstra
created the Dykstraflex, which allowed
for the camera to slowly
move around the model.
This better simulated movement
while still keeping the
shot perfectly stable.
Compared to more modern
motion-controlled rigs,
like the Bolt or the Cobra,
the Dykstraflex was very large,
moved very slowly, and its
angle movement were limited.
Despite its limits in hindsight,
this new rig system completely
revolutionized video capture.
It was one of the first
times camera movements
could be programmed into an,
albeit, very large computer,
so they could be precisely
replicated take after take.
This allowed editors to
add in multiple composites,
making arguably the most iconic
intergalactic battle scene of its time.
From there, this technology
entered more parts
of the video industry, from commercials
to smaller-scale projects,
like music videos.
Enter Camera Control,
which used the technology
to create some of the
most iconic music videos
of the '90s and early 2000s.
For the early projects,
Jason says the motion-controlled movements
were more static, used
mainly for super-precise pans
and to create slow-motion effects,
like in this Britney
Spears video from 2000.
Simon Wackley: So, we used the slower,
larger rigs for motion control,
but the faster rigs
really had their heyday
in the last four or five years.
They've been used more and more.
Well, I think a lot of the previous stuff
was heavy post-effects, heavy compositing.
And now I think it's more about
that dynamic camera move.
You go from ground level to high up
in, you know, a second or less.
Narrator: But this advancement
in music-video technology
didn't come immediately.
At the dawn of Y2K, the
music-video industry
faced its own mini apocalypse.
The whole music industry
was pretty much flipped upside down.
Physical media sales were
slowly becoming nonexistent.
Between 2000 and 2010,
CD sales dropped $9.8 billion in revenue.
That's because more consumers
started getting music online,
oftentimes illegally
through sites like LimeWire.
A lawsuit brought against LimeWire alleged
that LimeWire alone cost record labels
about $500 million a month in sales
and that users stole about
3 billion songs per month.
Jason: There were now new
digital platforms for music.
So the industry as a
whole was very confused
and just trying to figure
itself out and reinvent itself.
Narrator: At the time, Jason
says filming music videos
back then was a lot more expensive.
Cinematographers were shooting on film,
and productions needed bigger
crews to see projects through.
With this loss of income
from low record sales,
labels just weren't
investing in videos too much.
Jason: The slump in the
music-video industry
really didn't affect us
because we are involved
in many other facets of the industry.
We do a lot of feature film work,
a lot of commercial work.
Narrator: During the early 2000s,
Camera Control shifted
its shoots away from music
to feature films and
commercials using cinebots.
And food commercials were, and still are,
huge users of cinebot technology.
Jason: We do a lot of what's
called tabletop shooting,
and one of the main reasons
why this technology is used
in that part of the industry
is the precise control
that you have over the camera,
especially when you're shooting
at very high frame rates.
Narrator: High frame rates
are used to prevent blur
on fast-moving subjects, especially when
you want to create slow-motion effects.
But you need a lot of
stability to do it right.
Jason: Imagine you're shooting
at 1,000 frames a second
and you're trying to track
something falling through the air
and splashing into a glass of water.
Trying to do that by hand would
be super, super difficult.
Narrator: Meanwhile, music videos were
on the verge of a comeback.
Labels finally found ways to comfortably
capitalize on streaming in the 2010s
with the help of the advertising industry
and subscription services.
As of 2018, streaming
accounted for more than 75%
of all music consumption,
and ad revenue from streaming sites
helped to refill industry pockets.
At the same time, though,
YouTube, a new platform,
was moving past fun cat videos
and babies biting their siblings.
Harry: Ouch!
Narrator: Record companies
were finding new ways
to capitalize on the
seemingly endless exposure
that online video had to offer,
and with new video-publishing technology
came new video-capturing technology.
Camera Control would soon be
back in the music-video game.
Jason: Music videos have
come back in a big way,
for financial reasons and
for technical reasons.
Now you've got digital camera systems
that have become super small,
less expensive to purchase,
less expensive to rent.
Narrator: And with less
expensive technology
and fewer financial restrictions,
video directors like
"Humble" director Dave Meyers
reached out to Jason to
push visual boundaries.
That call would revolutionize
not only Jason's business,
but the hip-hop music video.
Meyers' crew attached smaller cameras
to cinebots, like the Bolt or Cobra,
and programmed them to move electronically
at super-precise angles around a subject.
The cinebot's fast-moving
tracking capability
is the core of what
makes "Humble" so iconic.
After the video was released,
the response was huge.
Not only to the video and the song,
but to the camera work.
Jason: After everyone
sort of saw that video,
we were getting calls and a lot of people
referencing that video for the type
of movements that they wanted to do.
Narrator: And since that watershed moment
when "Humble" dropped, Camera Control
has worked with artists like
ASAP Rocky and Post Malone,
and even some outside
of the hip-hop arena,
like K-pop group ONF.
When properly executed,
filming with cinebots
offers surreal,
larger-than-life perspectives.
Cinematographers can control
speeds in the foreground
and the background of any given shot.
And because the camera's
programmed to make
and repeat precise movements,
editors have multiple versions
to play with after filming ends.
It's this versatility that makes
the motion-controlled rigs so desirable
and why the technology will
be around for the long run.